[Music]
all right let's go out to Fort Worth
Texas home of the Rangers and talk to
Christopher what's up
Christopher hello John can you hear me I
can what's up
man hey um this is my first time on the
show been a long time listener um pretty
nervous but um we'll see how how this
how this goes hey I specifically told
the team no calls from the Dallas Fort
Worth area this week because you guys
just knocked out my Astros out of the
World
Series but yeah they they said this one
was important so here we go what's up
man um yeah so um so this question is um
is in regards to just just I'm not sure
this like a personality issue or just
something I'm overthinking um as an
adult I was inspired by one of your
calls um in the past week stating that
it's hard to make friends as a as an
adult which is true it's the worst a
little back yeah tell me about it um
just to give you a quick story I just
recently started a job and I want to be
more outgoing more friendly and stuff
like that for so I want to meet
co-workers so I want to meet co-workers
just to explain my network but honestly
it's so hard it's so hard to network to
make conversation in the workplace and
you know just it's just really difficult
um honestly I really I have I have
possibly like one or two friends but
then again when I called them they
always seem to be busy so honestly I I
don't I wouldn't said that have like a
close circle of friends so it's pretty
hard to to just get out there and just
um expand myself and expand my nck work
so I just want to see in your
perspective how how can I overcome this
um obstacle man that's a great question
dude
um couple of thoughts here so how long
youve been working at this new
place yeah I just recently started um
about like a month in I will say it
makes it more difficult because honestly
my department is mostly for with middle
age to to older women and I'm a young
male so oh yeah Christopher oh yeah I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding so so
honestly I'm not sure what to what to
bring up in a conversation when they're
talking about family stuff like this I'm
not I'm not sure what to go on from
there I just I just I'm probably just
the one employee or cooh that just sits
back to laugh and then if if I have like
a opinion or something then I stay my
opinion but I want to be more out there
more more connections more more
conversations and stuff like that I love
that so A couple of different things
circle in my mind here okay when it
comes to making new friends as an
adult the only two things I can think of
and I actually it's funny you mentioned
this I um I just I got like an obnoxious
amount of Journal articles like nerd
scientific research articles I want to
figure figure out like everything about
friendship cuz I don't know how it works
and so I'm with you like I'm trying to
figure this out and I'm going to go down
a rabbit hole for a while and figuring
it out for the next several months I
just want to learn everything about it
because I'm so perplexed by it but the
only thing I've got for you right now
when it comes to just globally speaking
about making new friends as an
adult is three things number one go
first number two just make peace with
being weird number three be
hospitable and so if you sit back and
wait it's going to always it's going to
feel like it never
comes and then if it does if it does
come you're on somebody else's
terms so you work in an office with four
or five or 10 or 15 middle-aged women
cool announce hey I want to go to lunch
with four or five of y'all and I want
you to teach me your secrets I'm buying
that's the hospitality part and it's
going to be expensive the first time but
I want you to take them out and here's a
magic thing so it's be weird go first be
hospitable hospitable mean hey I'm
having a Halloween get together at my
house I'd love to have y'all
come in your particular situation that's
that might not work that might be kind
of weird right um it might work at your
local church it might work at your local
like I don't know what Hobbies you're
into and you might be like I don't have
any hobbies well it might be time to
like go take Jiu-Jitsu or go take a
welding class or go do some things that
are going to put you with other people
in your age demographic Etc okay but
when it comes to work when it comes to
meeting new people go first be weird and
be hospitable just have them over well I
got a little bitty apartment it's kind
of weird have them over anyway the only
time I would say don't have them over is
if you still live at your mom's house
okay that could be super weird right
in your
situation I have found one of the
greatest gifts we can give another
person is to ask about their life and to
listen to
them and so when they're talking about
family and you're just sitting back
cracking up you're
laughing instead of trying to think of
the right thing to add to the
conversation the right thing to
say when somebody's talking about their
dingdong husband did this again I can't
believe that a great gift you could give
them is to say hey I'm young are you
single Chris are you
single oh I'm sorry um yes yes I am okay
perfect hey I'm young and single how did
that guy get somebody as beautiful and
awesome as you I want to hear your story
and just let it go okay okay and what
you're doing is giving somebody an
opportunity to tell their story and they
might smile the whole time because
they're going to remember back to when
she actually liked her husband or their
romance story or she's going to get
choked up because the marriage is over
the guy passed away here was the story
from the past but you are letting them
you are providing them an opportunity to
get in touch with some important
feelings in their life and that makes
you a really valuable human
being okay and whenever they talk
instead of leaning back which you
probably do I want you to consciously
Lean Forward on one elbow just a little
bit and it's going to feel awkward but I
want you to lean towards them a little
bit because that tells their body this
guy's safe and he's
listening okay okay think to ask more
questions than think what's the right
thing to say
here okay yeah and and also to add um
yeah that that that's great advice um
yeah I tried so hard to just search up
articles YouTube videos and stuff like
that but honestly
um I'm not I'm not sure if you know I'm
just I'm just trying to find what to say
and what what what's a good conversation
starter everybody likes to talk about
themsel okay
everybody okay and also to add I also
want to expand like as as I mentioned
like my department mostly consist of of
ladies also want to expand to other
department but I'm not sure since since
I'm not in depart in their department
and uh I really don't understand what
what they do for work um I'm not sure
with it like that's it yeah I do want
that's it that's your
question hey can I take you to coffee
and just learn about what y'all
do uh what hey I'm over in Department X
I'm surrounded by like 35 middle-aged
women I want to learn about what you
guys are doing over here in this part of
the company can I buy you coffee okay
and what you're doing is not like hey
man will you come be my friend cuz
that's weird right that would make you
weird or hey you want to go talk about
chicks I don't know what weird weird
thing you're going to get on the
internet I guess this is going on the
internet so that might be a weird thing
but sitting down and asking somebody
dude so tell me like what do y'all do
over here in this in this part of the
company and letting them talk and then
say are you married well yeah how'd that
happen
man you got kids yeah I got two kids
dude what's the best part of being a dad
like I'm not a dad yet what's the
scariest part of being a dad and you're
going to look up and you're going to
have spent an hour and that person has
mostly talked about
themsel and you've given them such a
gift to clarify what they love about
their job or to be honest about what
they don't like about their job to talk
about possibly their favorite thing
which is their wife or their kids or to
clarify some things they're struggling
with at home which might be their wife
and their kids but it's going in there
to ask questions and the question you
just asked
I don't know who told you bro that your
questions aren't good but you just told
me like I don't even know what they do
over there awesome go ask them they
would love to tell you and if they don't
if they're like yeah I'm not going to
coffee with you minion you do not want
to spend two seconds with them they're
not worth your
time okay all right and let me leave you
with
this I don't know who in your life told
you that you're weird and don't aren't
good at having
friends but if you woke up how old are
you right
now I'm currently 25 okay you woke up
and you're 25 and you're looking around
and you don't have a ton of friends it's
not because you're weird or broken it's
because we've created a world where
friendships are so hard to come by and
they're so hard to keep they're
impossible
right yeah there's nothing wrong with
you brother you're not somehow broken
and you need to get on the internet and
figure out some
things you got to be weird you got to go
first you got to be hospitable and you
got to say dude tell me about
you okay then eventually they're going
to ask you like well how did you come
here and you can tell your story and now
y'all are having a
conversation okay sounds good yeah like
I said um I mean not just in a workplace
you know it's difficult but then even in
the outside world it's pretty scary
honestly um like I said I really don't I
really don't got much friends and you
always talk about having a close circle
around you it honestly I feel like I
don't have that at all yeah um but yeah
I gota be you got to put yourself in
that position yeah you got to put
yourself in that world whether that's
again signing up for some
classes joining a running club taking
Jiu-Jitsu taking a woodworking class um
taking a drone flying I'm just making
stuff up but you got to put yourself in
a position to where you're going to run
into other people you can't just go to
work at 25 and then go home Scott
Galloway who um has got some great
messages he tells young people be at
home as little as possible you're 25
years old be at home as little as
possible continue to put yourself in
situations whether at your local church
joining a softball league a soccer team
uh whatever put yourself in situations
just go if you're going to sit at home
and and read go do it in Starbucks
you're going to run into people and
someone's going to say hey can I borrow
that chair and you're like yeah you can
sit down here man where do you work and
now you're Off to the Races but I don't
want you to overthink it and overthink
it and overthink it and overthink it but
I do want you to start putting yourself
out there and the best way to put
yourself out there is to ask tell me
about you tell me about you and I think
you're going to find people love talking
about themselves and you're going to
give them a great gift which is to feel
things they haven't felt in a long time
because they've been sitting all by
themselves too you're awesome my brother
I want you to try this out for like a
month or two and then holler back girl
at me I ain't a holler back girl holler
back and let me know how it's going
I bet you the tide will begin to turn
you're awesome
man